[Music]
i didn't really have the skill enough to
um
to write the book experiments lead to
other experiments
lead to successes you couldn't even
imagine possible when you first did the
experiment
so james elder cher becomes president
believe nation super excited to have a
three-time
guest now on the show author of the new
book
skip the line mr james
altucher evan thank you so much once
again
how long have we we've known each other
for years i don't know it's been a while
it's been a while i mean the last time
we talked about your how to think like a
billionaire
um and then we did choose yourself which
is your your you know
legendary book uh i don't know it's been
a while dude it's been a while but yeah
you to me are the mad scientist of
entrepreneurship
uh i mean i'll i'll take it you've got
the hair which is always great you know
i'm jealous
you got the hair but but you're you're
always you're so curious
you might be the most curious person
i've ever met
always trying to pick people's brains on
things and then you just go out and try
it
and some things work and some things
don't and you
kind of tweak from there and then and
then what i love is then you share
the learnings you share what what you
took from it but also share hey i
i really screwed this up and i'm not
doing that again
so you i just see you as the mad
scientist of entrepreneurship
well and i appreciate that and you know
what you the one thing you said like
some things work some things don't most
things don't
work and if if most things worked then
life would be too easy most things work
and then there's a lot of challenges
when something doesn't work like well
did we learn anything
well did did they not work so badly that
we went
broke or we got scared to try again did
we
set it up in such a way that you know we
learned something and
and now we can tell at least a story
about it so the downside there's
downside but there's also upside
like there's a lot of nuances to this
doesn't work
if that makes sense yeah and what i love
about you is you
at least seem to be unafraid to ask
for help where when you're trying to
learn something you just
reach out and say hey i'm i'm trying to
learn this
can you give me some guidance or or do
you want to come on my show and let's
talk about it and you can
expose all my flaws and tell me where
i'm when my thinking is wrong
uh and a lot of people i think i think
that fear paralyzes them they're afraid
of being rejected they're afraid of
that person saying no and you just seem
at least from the outside
to be unafraid to ask people for help a
i think i really used to be
very much afraid to ask people to help
for help i think i had like
what what is sometimes called a fixed
mindset where
oh my gosh i don't want people to
realize i'm not smart so i better not
ask for help i
i mean i had to really learn the hard
way like going broke several times
before i finally learned how to be able
to ask for help but the other thing is
i'm still that's something you're always
learning like
nobody ever really solves their
weaknesses and my weakness is i am
afraid to ask
for help i even once got a deal to write
a book called the power of ask
after i wrote a book called the power of
no and the same publisher wanted me to
write the power of ask and i
got in advance and everything and i
realized i didn't really
i didn't really have the skill enough to
um
to write the book so i i turned it down
and and didn't write the book
but it's still it's still a process for
me
wow all right i like it well maybe
that's the next one after skip the line
maybe so anyway new book here it is skip
the line
uh for my audience we'll link it up in
the description below so so go check it
out
the concept is yes you need to go get
mastery and we've all heard of the 10
000 hour rule but but you can also you
can skip the line you can get there
faster you can use hacks to accomplish
your goals more quickly
what do you think is the i mean there's
lots of hacks in here but what's one do
you think that people
could immediately apply to accomplish
their goals faster
oh my god there's so there's so many
because i really set this up
like i didn't want this to be some bs
book
where it's like oh here's some theories
of academic research about how people
learn and how people are successful and
so on
these are all techniques that i
personally did
when i was stuck or lost and or i was
switching interest and switching
passions
or i needed to switch interest so i
could make money
in some new career and i had no idea
what
and so i wanted to make these things as
simple as possible because often when
we're in a difficult situation if
someone gives us some complex or
academic theory
it's not going to work we're not going
to do it and so
so okay like one one thing
that i write about here which was like
new for me was
something i call the 10 000 experiment
role and i felt like i was really
hampered by the so-called ten thousand
hour rule like to get good at something
you have to spend ten thousand hours at
it
doing it and i was struggling with this
because i didn't want to spend ten 000
hours learning
a new skill that i was passionate about
i'm um you know that's 10 years or 20
years who
who knows along and then what if you
learn it and you can't make money at it
which you know is never addressed in the
10 000 hour rule
so i wrote about something called the 10
000 experiment role although it's really
more like
a hundred experiments and the idea is is
that
if you want to learn something quickly
good enough to be in the top one percent
in the world in it you need to not
repeat over and over and over again for
10 000 hours
but try experiments like try to
ask questions that no one else has
really asked or answered before
about the thing that you're very
interested in and very passionate about
and then do experiments around those
questions so for instance
uh you know let's say i want to learn
stand-up comedy and at one point
i did want to learn it i still love
learning it i love stand-up comedy and i
perform
regularly and so on well i i wanted to
get better at dealing with
hostile audiences the kind of audience
that will heckle me particularly when i
was
first starting out and i wanted to get
my jokes
tighter like a little quicker to get to
the laugh point
so i did an experiment i went on a
subway
and i started doing stand-up on a subway
a new york city subway car and you can't
find a more hostile
dangerous audience and
i will go from car to car every stop and
i would just start doing comedy
and telling jokes to people and they did
not
nearly subway car uh rush hour they did
not
want anybody talking to them and
i did it and first of all i should say
the characteristic
experiment should be cheap to do easy to
do
little downside massive upside so the
downside here was
a bunch of strangers on their way home
would la
would would would yell at me or be upset
at me or not like me
and the upside was is that i would get
better at dealing with a certain kind of
audience i would get a lot of ex
fast experience it's not that easy to
get on stage over and over again in a
few hours so you could try these ideas
out
so this was a way to do it and the
upside is that i
i learned and the doubt again the
downside
was i also learned like i had and i have
a story to tell because i did this
and that's one way doing stand-up comedy
that i was able to get better relatively
quickly doing experiments like that that
put me in difficult situations and
forced me to learn very quickly on my
feet or if you're starting a business
you know an experiment is put up
make an ad put a just a 20 budget behind
it put the ad on facebook
for a product that you think might be
attractive see if people click on it
and they could click to an empty page
you're just measuring the clicks if it
gets a lot of clicks
there might be interest in a product
like this if it doesn't get any clicks
probably there's no interest or you know
your ad was bad so you have to
have an experiment about that maybe do a
bunch of ads but
you know everything you do everything
you're learning you should
you should construct experiments that
will
help you get better there's little
downside thomas edison famously
tried ten thousand wires before he
successfully
invented the light bulb and someone
asked him
how did it feel to uh fail ten thousand
times in a row because he tried ten
thousand different wires
and he said sir i i didn't fail 10 000
times i just found out
10 000 ways how not to make a light bulb
and you know having that kind of
philosophy of experimentation allowed
him to
create invent all these inventions and
create a huge company general electric
so that that's one role another one i i
like to
use pretty regularly i mean i like i use
all of them
is but another one i like to use is plus
minus equal
when you want to learn something very
fast and this was taught to me by
someone who had to learn life or death
skills very quickly
uh but but if you want to learn
something very fast
get a plus which is either a real or
virtual mentor or coach
get equals find people who are rising up
in the industry
who you know you could you could
challenge each other take you know
give each other ideas and so on and find
a minus and this is maybe the most
important
find someone to teach because even
einstein said if you can't explain
something simply
then you don't really understand it and
i have found through my own
teaching that i learned more from the
minus than from the plus even
because when you are able to ex explain
basic concepts
to someone who doesn't know as much as
you it gives you a much
uh more nuanced understanding of those
basics
and i could give examples later if you
want and then and then
also it's a very important thing here
too which is it's not
good it's not good enough to simply be
in the top one percent of your field
and yes i'm absolutely sure using these
techniques you can get in the top one
percent of your field because
i've done it many times unfortunately
i've gotten broke many times i've had to
start
from scratch many times i had to do this
but
just as important or even equal you know
even more important
you have to know the field very well you
could be the best writer in the world
but if you don't know the field of
writing and publishing you're not going
to be successful
you could you could be a great salesman
or you could be a a great
um software engineer and have all sorts
of ideas but if you don't know how
venture capital works silicon valley
works
um business works you're not gonna make
money you're not gonna be
really successful so there's a lot of
people out there like oh here's how to
learn or here's how to
be good at business but they they don't
realize the two things go
hand in hand that i have never seen a
book until this about
how these uh things go hand in hand and
and it's important to understand both to
really
master a topic and and monetize it and
and you know mastery is important for
uh for happiness and well-being but so
is freedom
which means that you can do what you
want and maybe be financially successful
and so is community which means
find other people who love the same
things and and learn with them
and you know that's what really this
book is about is
how to find well-being by doing what you
love and having the freedom to
pursue it so going back to the subway
story
logically it makes sense it's cheap you
don't care about these people
uh you could it's available you can just
do it right now you're in new york you
don't have to travel anywhere you can
just go
logically makes sense emotionally it's a
big hurdle for a lot of people
oh man i was so scared i can't even tell
you but that's also the nature of
experiments
is that almost by definition you're
doing something
that hasn't really been done and
you know it's very it's very scary but
uh you know there's there's lots of
experiments uh that i do
i wanted to improve my writing about a
year ago or maybe two years ago
and instead of just writing a normal
article
uh which i've done thousands of i
decided to write it in the context of
creating a kickstarter
campaign so it was basically about why
did donald trump tweet
i want to buy greenland and the prime
minister of denmark tweeted back
it's not for sale and i was fascinated
by this because like
you can buy greenland i didn't hey i
didn't know that
b what does denmark have to do with
greenland i had no idea
c are these world leaders really
negotiating for a country
on twitter and so i did my research and
i'm like oh
somebody really needs to buy greenland
this is a serious global issue
and but then i was like okay if i just
write an article about this no one's
gonna read it it doesn't sound that
interesting like oh
here's why you should buy greenland but
so i did it as a kickstarter and so i
explained all the reasons why
i wanted to raise a hundred million
dollars on kickstarter to buy greenland
and here's why i thought that was
important so now i'm doing it in the
context of a kickstarter campaign
just the same way you know in writing
some people write an article
in the form of letters back and forth to
each other that's called an epistolary
style
article or you could write an article in
the third person or the second person or
whatever
and uh so i wrote basically i made a
kickstarter campaign where i write
my reasons and have a little story
behind it and but then also i have to
make these tears like if you give
a hundred dollars i'll make you a duke
if you give a thousand dollars
i'll make a holiday after you if you
give ten thousand dollars
uh you know you get ten thousand acres
of land and whatever
and so it was interesting and then it
actually started raising money people
started sharing it around
it was up to about two thousand dollars
which is not a lot i was trying to raise
a hundred million
but kickstarter shut it down because
they didn't as they explained to me they
want to be responsible for the
credit card fees when i somehow would
not succeed in my
goal of raising 100 million but again it
was an interesting way to play with
formats in writing
i the experiment failed i didn't get to
buy greenland
but i had never done a kickstarter
project before so i learned about
kickstarter i learned about greenland
which i knew nothing about
and i learned about writing always
moving the needle a little forward on
writing because you
you're always the student never never
the master
and uh you know that's another example
experiment and
at any given point i'm doing like five
to ten experiments
all the time like i'm always i'm always
in the process of doing various
experiments
well i love it that's fine that's why
you are the mad scientist of
entrepreneurship
uh but but just how do you get over that
fear because i think that's where a lot
of people
stumble i think oh oh yeah so so i'm
sorry i didn't i didn't
address it so i get on the subway with
my friend who's gonna take a video
and i said to her okay um
this is a waste of time sorry i brought
you into this i'm not gonna do this i'm
too i'm too terrified and she was like
okay
and then we're just on the subway
because we're on the subway now we have
to stay on till the next stop
and i said you know what just turn on
the video
and if i feel like it i'll do it i'm not
feeling like it but
just turn on the video and then she
turned on the video
and then i just started i don't know how
i started i just you kind of just take
that leap and you
you realize there really is no downside
like the worst case
is i suck at this and
no one will laugh and this is what i was
trying to experiment on anyway
and that's it that's the only down
there's no real downside a bunch of
strangers
not liking me is the downside and so you
get over the fear by
kind of acknowledging how how trivial
it is this experiment you're doing and
the the other way
is is you kind of lean into the fear a
little bit
like for instance i don't ever publish
an article
unless i'm afraid of of what people will
think of me
so so literally my finger will be about
to hit
return to publish an article and i
always stop myself and i
really question am i afraid of what
people will think of me
if i hit publish and if the answer is no
i'm not afraid
then i won't publish it and i'll rework
it
or not or just drop it because if you're
not afraid
if you're if you're doing something that
where there's no fear
component then you're already you're
doing something that anybody can do and
you're doing something
that's probably already been done so
you're not really adding to the
global conversation of whatever
skill or industry you're trying to
pursue so then what's the point
if i'm going to write 50 shades of gray
again
well it's already been written i don't
need to write that nobody nobody in the
world needs that
and by the way i did an experiment that
proved that
which i could describe uh i i
took 50 shades of gray and i took a
thesaurus
and i rewrote 50 shades of grey
but i wrote the exact same story
word for word except every word was a
synonym of the word
el james used when she wrote fifty
shades of gray
and then i published it on amazon under
a fake name
and i wanted to see if there would be
any buyers and there was like 50 buyers
instead of
10 million buyers so nobody really
wanted a 700 page
new version of 50 shades of gray that
was all synonyms of the original
so that was an experiment along those
lines of you don't like to publish
something unless you
risk offending somebody or
misinterpreting
what's a an opinion you're playing with
right now or an experiment you're
working on
or a thought process that may be sharon
on this video
people might not understand or see you
as
a weird duck well i
i i will admit this i didn't vote in the
recent election
not for not really for political reasons
about the democrats or republicans
but i sort of feel like why don't we
have more choices
uh i feel like the political system we
should acknowledge that
there are more than two opinions that
are important on an issue
and i was really disappointed that ev
that
75 million people believe the exact same
thing about 100 different issues
and then 75 million other people give or
take
believe the exact same opposite about
all 100 issues like the
statistical correlation would be
you know one over infinity would be
impossible and
so it was just clearly nobody really
understood issues and
but then i i would tell people i'm not
voting and they would get very
upset at me like they would say you're
a racist or this is the most important
election ever
or if you don't vote then you don't have
a right
to speak about issues and i'm like
really
one vote out of 150 million and you're
gonna say that to me
or you're gonna say i'm a racist you
have no idea
what i believe in but you just
automatically say that
i might just be making a statement about
the political system and they would say
people
died for your right to vote yeah my
right to vote not my obligation to vote
so here's an experiment i did
uh and it's still ongoing shortly after
the election
i went to fec.gov which is in the united
states it's the website for the federal
elections commission and like every
other candidate for
president i filled out some basic
paperwork and i encourage all your
listeners to do this it's a valuable
experiment to learn about our
democracy and our democratic process i
filled out all the paperwork
and i officially filed to run for
president united states in 2024. so
technically i am an official candidate
for president united states
in 2024 just like i assume
joe biden will be and who knows who else
will be
running and uh i
because so then if anyone ever says to
me well you don't have the right to
speak about anything
i could say well i'm running for
president united states what are what
are you doing
but uh it was an it's an interesting
experiment because
a if it forced me to discover a lot of
things i didn't know
about the presidential process in terms
of all the filings the fundraisings
um and then i also learned there are
kind of there are a lot of people
running for president
there's like a thousand candidates for
president of 2020 there there were
you know many that you don't have no
clue of and they all have little
websites and
i don't know if they were doing it as a
joke or they were serious or whatever
and so then i started talking you know
once you do something you start getting
a cognitive bias to learn more about
what it is you're doing
so i started talking to political
consultants
about well what should i do next and
people gave me start giving me really
good advice
like asking me about my issues and then
you know particularly people who are
professional campaign managers they
explain to me
what type of issues resonate with voters
what type of issues don't so you can
still be honest about your issues which
i think very few people are
but but still come up with the issues
campaign on the issues that you think
people will
resonate with so i'm still going through
this process but it's
it's fascinating to to learn about the
political process by actually
engaging in in it almost tongue-in-cheek
like originally was tongue-in-cheek
but now some people are convincing me
that my issues are interesting enough
maybe i should take it seriously kind of
like an
andrew yang situation are you gonna cast
your vote in 2024 then
well i might cast it for myself exactly
back to the book skip the line what what
do you think
the lesson that the president needs to
play is from here
the president yeah yeah if you're gonna
sit down he hasn't read the book
you're gonna pull out one lesson from
here that could change
his life or what he should be doing for
america what what lesson would you pull
out
that's a really great question no one
has asked me that well
i can go almost chapter by chapter but i
i know you want uh
there's 23 different techniques in the
book but one thing i would i would say
is
and this is very important there's no
such skill as
president it's not like i will be a good
president there's no such skill it's
really a collection of skills
one of the skills of course is politics
you have to be good at politics
another skill is leadership which is
different than politics
another skill is you gotta you gotta
have
ideas that are that are unique that you
think can help
ideas that nobody else would have
thought of or if you don't have those
that
that creativity then you have to have
skills in delegation
and execution and um
negotiating and diplomacy and
persua you know persuasion and kind of
the psychology of reading people whether
it's a world leader or a voter or
congress person that you're talking to
you have to you have to have a good
skill at reading people
and so i if i was president i would
identify what are all the skills
i really need to be master of to to
manage the free world and by the way a
lot of uh
interesting endeavors or industries are
like this like there's no such skill as
business
there's this basket of micro skills and
i have a chapter on microscopes it's a
basket of micro skills like
businesses you know ideation execution
management
marketing selling negotiating creating
value of your company
and there's a whole bunch of micro
skills that are different from each
other that you need to learn
to be good at quote-unquote business
which is not one skill by itself
there's no such skill as tennis you have
to be good at the backhand the forehand
the neck game the serve
and so on if you're good at the serve it
has nothing to do with whether you're
gonna have a good backhand or not you
have to get good at all these micro
skills
so the first thing is i'd encourage the
president to identify the micro skills
and either get good at them
or really make sure you delegate well
which is itself
a like i said a micro skill of being
president
the other thing is is i have a chapter
called conspiracy numbers
and that's like how do you make every
decision a president makes
has rewards but also risks
and you want the rewards
to outshine the risks and so i have a
chapter called conspiracy numbers which
is
which basically in a nutshell is how
many things have to conspire
in order for the rewards to be
worth it and uh uh the more
things that have to conspire the less
likely it is you're going to have
the rewards so if if i have to convince
um you know if i want to pass an
amendment for instance a constitutional
amendment
you need like two-thirds of the united
states to uh
with the states to agree with this not
only the senate and the congress but all
the states and they have to do it fairly
quickly
so that's too many things that have to
conspire in order for me to push through
a constitutional amendment
but if i have to you know change
taxes or or change a rule on you know
whatever issue is important to me
and i think most of congress is on my
side that there's fewer things that have
to conspire so you want to focus on the
things
that are really effective but don't have
a high cons
what i call a conspiracy number uh the
other thing is
um uh you know
you obviously don't want to do
experiments with the american people but
you do want to figure out
how to you know
you're making very dangerous decisions
often and you kind of have to
understand what's going through the
effects of these decisions and maybe
there's ways i can try it out
in like a municipality or a state or
whatever before
it gets rolled nationwide if you have an
opinion about education or schools or
school meals
do it in a town and you know you don't
do it without haphazardly don't don't
risk
people's health or anything but do it
see how it works and then roll it out so
this idea of experiments
is is very important and of course um
you know uh plus minus equals is is very
important like
when bill clinton became president of
the united states you know who the first
person he spoke to was
to get advice nope uh richard james
no um that was only
i did speak to him but many years after
he was president
and not on epstein's island i should add
but um
he the first person he called or one of
the first people he called was richard
nixon
who is notorious for you know almost
being impeached and
and the only president who have resigned
but
richard nixon was you know effectively
ended the vietnam war
he established political or diplomatic
relations with china
so love him or hate him he was a very
effective president
and and again i have no opinion good or
bad on on nixon
but clinton wanted advice on how to be
president from nixon
so that was his plus uh in addition to
all the equals so he gathered together a
bunch of
academics and intellectuals for a
conference right in the beginning of his
term
to get ideas from from what he viewed as
as his equals
and he had minuses also he was he be
he trained himself to be to go from
being a horrible
uh speech maker to a good one so he
could learn how to explain things
simply and he's very effective at that
and
so he he he did the plus-minus sequel
and hopefully other
presidents did as well and i don't know
just a lot of the techniques
in the book i think would be very useful
for for a president i would use them if
i was president
these are all techniques again i wish
someone had told me when i was younger
instead of me
having to go broke and come back and go
broke and come back in order to
figure these out so let's pull on this
thread a little bit more because it's
fun so
so james eldertr becomes president it's
happened ladies and gentlemen
2024 there he is i'm curious
back to your plus minus equal strategy
who are the
three who are three pluses that you
immediately reach out to
and what's the micro skill that you want
to pick up from them
yeah that's such a great question i love
pulling on this thread no one has no one
has done that
and uh uh you know i
i guess who would who would be better to
explain things than a former president
so i probably would talk to
someone like and by the way you don't
have to agree with them i'm sure clinton
didn't agree with nixon
there one was a democrat the other was a
republican although
you know these things mean different
things every decade uh
but i probably would want to talk to uh
uh clinton
and if not if not w
then maybe dick cheney um uh
obama was was it would be an interest i
mean all of them but like
and even trump would be an interesting
person to talk to like
did trump trump was actually
very effective in the sense that what he
said he would do
he often did and he was very
straightforward about it
uh clinton was often like that too um
i i've heard different things depending
on who you talk to
i like to talk to people from other
countries about their perception
of our presidents because it's it's
usually not bogged down in
political rhetoric and they're usually
able to say oh this person did this for
us and this person
said he would do it but didn't do it so
you get a lot of opinions about
everybody
but i would want to learn from someone
like obama or clinton about
being diplomatic with with congress
they're very good diplomats they're very
good diplomats either with congress or
foreign leaders
so that's a very good um at giving
speeches
that's a very valuable skill someone
like cheney
i'd want to get his sense of of the
world situation and does he think he
made a mistake
uh with the wars i mean i'm hoping he
thinks he made it
and and someone like trump i'd want to
learn why did he not care at all
what people would think of him he was
like a uh
what's it expression like an elephant in
a china shop or something
and you know did he learn from that so
that's the
pluses uh the the my the equals
would be all the other candidates who
ran
and lost i'd want to confer with someone
like an andrew yang
or a marco rubio or uh
you know bernie sanders or uh
you know another one on the republican
side like a jeb bush or whatever
so you know they're kind of people who
thought a lot about running for the
presidency
and so and they lost but i wanted to
know why they want to run
what where do they think they went wrong
what could they have done better
and on and on and uh the minuses
is being able to explain
to run a country you have to have very
complicated creative ideas
and but you but but the people don't
want that they don't want ideas that are
hard to understand they don't want
uh an intellectual and you know adlai
stevenson
ran for president in 1952 in 1956
against eisenhower and lost both times
and he was called an egghead people just
didn't like it when you had complicated
ideas
and so i'd want to learn how to expl i
want to learn
how to explain comp relatively
complicated ideas
to 300 million people as as
in as simple as fashion as possible and
so that would be
i'd learn from the minus you know
because i have ideas that i think are
good but
i don't even i don't quite know how to
explain them yet and
you know so i would use that that
technique i mean i would use the
i would use plus minus equals in those
ways who do you think does a great job
of that i mean we talked about
einstein's
idea that if you can't explain it to an
average person you don't know it well
enough but who do you think
living right now does a great job of
taking these super complex topics
and making it very digestible for people
well
in every industry the top one percent of
that industry
is is good at it like that's how they
got to the top you can't get to the top
one percent
of of an industry and i don't mean in
the skills now i mean
in the field you can't get to the top
one percent of an industry unless you're
good at plus minus equal
so for instance i interviewed the other
day jeff immelt
who was for 16 years the ceo of ge now
ge
makes aircraft engines electric grids
you know turbines and all these
complicated things and they're in many
different industries
and i'm i'm able to ask him what's a
turbine and
he would i could see he's able to
explain things very very simply
and i would ask him things about success
and he was just very gracious and and
and answered them in such a simple way
and i felt like this real
rapport with him even though we had just
met on zoom on the podcast
and so i think he was he was an example
of someone very good at it
but i'm sure evan you're very good at it
like let's say you're talking about
how to do a podcast and you're
explaining to a beginner i bet you're
very good like here are the things you
need to know about interviewing here are
the things
like you're doing a very good job now
you've asked questions i've been on
a bunch of podcasts but skip the line
you've asked a dozen different questions
that nobody has
asked before so you're a very good
interviewer and i'm sure you're able to
explain that
simply to someone who doesn't know how
to interview it's a very hard skill
and uh you know you also have done a lot
of work on success i'm sure you can
explain
very in very simple terms what success
is and so on
so i'm doing an experiment right now
which is uh
so just to set the stage for it in
the 90s in in the mid 90s i was
i played a lot of chess and i was a
at my peak i was a extremely strong
master
at chess like i was winning tournaments
i was winning money and
and and so on but if you don't study
something for
23 years you're going to lose all your
skills at it like if you don't play golf
for 23 years
you you're going to go from a one
handicap to
a 20 handicap say so i'm like at a 20
handicap
in chess or i was and so i decided a few
months ago i'm going to use the skip the
line techniques
very disciplined i'm going to use all of
them and i'm only going to use these
techniques
to get as good as i was
before at chess and again i'm probably
about
probably when i started this experiment
the
old me the peak version of me could
probably beat
me now uh me a few months ago
three out of four times and i wanted to
get
just as good as i used to be and even
better
and here it is three months later i'm
definitely
now just as good as i used to be using
specifically to skip the line
techniques and uh now i'm on the road to
getting better than i
ever was before and by doing this
experiment not only am i proving to
myself that once again these
skip the line techniques are very
powerful chess is a very
complex field to to master but
uh i'm also learning about learning like
it's it's interesting what i'm how i
look at something that i mastered 23
years ago
and how it appears to me now it's much
because
i'm different i see uh chest
it differently and it's just been a very
fascinating experience
so so another reason to to master
something other than the pleasure it
gives is that
you you learn what it is to to master a
topic or an industry or
or a skill and there's a lot of
the it's always that case the more you
learn the more they're the more you
realize there is to learn
and i never fully appreciated that
before until
until now are you james altucher
trying to master learning
maybe because i mean these not only
master learning but
but bridge the learning to the the times
we're in
i mean 55 million people in the us got
laid off
in in 2020 and and filed for
unemployment
and it's very it's very important that
you not only master a skill but that
you're able to translate it into
something practical
that you could make money with as and
that's not crass like we all have to pay
the bills
and you know i'll just use
chess as an example i know extremely
strong players for instance the guy i
take lessons from
is a very strong lesson you know so i
have a plus and i take lessons from a
very strong player
but he's not he's not like one of the
top 10 players in the world
and to make a living playing chess you
kind of have to be in the top ten it's
not the most lucrative
sport it's not like tennis or something
and
but uh he he
streams on twitch and chess watching on
twitch has exploded in popularity
uh perhaps because of the tv show the
queen's gambit
but he's he he has more followers on
youtube now than like some of the best
comedians in the world who are
professional entertainers
and he's making a great living now
playing chess even though he's not one
of the best in the world
so you know again they work together
learning about skills and learning about
the field
go hand in hand i worked for hbo for a
while
and i made i shot a pilot for them i did
an original web show for them and so i
had to learn
about entertainment doing that but it
wasn't enough to just come up with an
entertaining idea
i had to learn why is this appropriate
for hbo
but not for cbs why um you know
what could this was in the 90s so what
what could an original web show look
like
if it became a tv show or what does what
does an hbo feel like if it's on
the internet and not television and and
so i would read the wall street journal
every day like the entertainment section
you know what was happening with viacom
time warner sony
you know you have to learn the field so
that you could you could
almost become one with the industry so
that you feel like
when you say or do something you're
having an effect on the entire industry
you almost have to speak with the
industry's voice
and again that's the value of
understanding the field and it's just as
important as
you need the skills of course but you
need the field and and that's very
important so
i'll use 50 shades of grey as another
example eel james
not the best writer in the world i'm not
insulting her by saying that i'm sure
she
knows that as well but by the way she's
the best-selling author in the world
so what's the relationship between skill
and financial success in the writing
industry
and how did she get published if she's a
if she's not a good writer
well she didn't get published the
traditional way she self-published
sold 250 000 copies got rejected by a
ton of publishers and then i think it
was simon schuster or one of them
that took a chance on this horrible
writer
and she became the best selling author
on the planet
something some uh something there was a
one month where like one out of every
two books sold were
was fifty shades of grey and she
single-handedly saved the publishing
industry back whenever that was
so again it was her understanding of the
field of publishing that led
her to to almost more success than her
skill in
writing and by the way she was skillful
enough to write
a book that everybody read certainly in
the top one percent of all
writers just maybe not like hemingway
level she's not going to win the nobel
prize
but you don't have to be many many great
writers are not financially successful
at all
i love that you said kind of bridge the
practicality and why i said are you
just trying to master learning because
in a lot of the stories
there seems to be no practical outcome
of
running for president trying to buy
greenland
fifty shades of gray and the source
switch it up like there doesn't seem to
be a plausible
this is gonna make me money or there's
no kind of
end game apart from i'm going to learn a
whole lot about this thing and in
learning
i'm going to be able to then teach other
people so i'm trying to master learning
or
if that's not the thinking help me
bridge that gap of you seem to take on a
whole bunch of
seemingly impractical things that don't
make any sense
and you still go for them so how does
that tie up to i'm not just wasting my
time
well okay like one time i did an
experiment this is in the oos
and i could talk about more recent ones
too but um one time i did an experiment
where
i was writing for uh thestreet.com and
the wall street journal
and so i wrote a daily article that i
called blog watch blogs were
the thing and i would link every single
morning
to the top 10 blogs of the night before
about that were about finance or stocks
or whatever
and the experiment ostensibly was
would people be interested in this and
it turns out it was the most popular
article every day
on thestreet.com and so
that experiment worked and i was paid
per article so
suddenly i had this almost franchise to
myself
of and i would get paid every i was
writing it five or six days a week
so i was getting so i was making money
directly because that experiment worked
and so everybody the street.com wouldn't
want me to cancel it because it was
working it was
generating more money in ads and they
were paying me
so i was getting paid for it and it was
a decent living if all i did was that
that was like a decent enough
salary and it started as an experiment
but
even deeper because every day i was
linking to all these blogs
i got to know like basically the top 1
000 bloggers
in the finance space so when i did
another
business which was um a site called
stock picker that was kind of a
social media meets finance uh
i was able to contact every blogger who
got the bulk of their traffic from me
by the way and i would say hey i would
love it if you check out
my website stockpicker and maybe write
about it
it's just a request i didn't demand
anything and they all wrote about it
and reviewed it favorably it was a very
good website and
the first month i had over a million
registered users
and i was selling ads and i had no
employees
so i was selling 90 000 worth of ads a
month and i know employees
four months after i officially launched
the site i sold it so for
millions of dollars i went broke two
years later
so that's another story but that's an
example where experiments lead to other
experiments
lead to successes you couldn't even
imagine possible when you first did the
experiment so that's why it's good
whatever you're curious about
do experiments around whatever you want
um
to learn skills in you know do the plus
minus equals do experiments and so on
but i do have specific techniques in the
book for just learning the field which
is
you know you need to know persuasion and
i have my own take on persuasion that's
different from from all the kind of
academic research
i i only write about techniques that
very specifically
work for me and i have another technique
called
um the spoken wheel technique so let's
say let's say you love sports
okay one sports is the wheel
now think of all the spokes about how to
make money well you could be an athlete
but evan
probably you and i aren't going to be a
professional a world-class professional
athlete at this point
and at least me i shouldn't talk for you
i'm sorry um
but you know or i could um
get involved in fantasy sports or i can
get involved in
using ai to protect sports outcomes kind
of like a money ball
sort of approach or i could write a
newsletter about sports
or a course about sports or i can make
i i could maybe invent a new tennis
racket with a different type of material
for the strings who knows if i know a
little about that or
i could do there's another chapter in
the book called idea calculus i could do
idea sex so a friend of mine
is was a trader at jp morgan he traded
bonds at jp morgan
so he loved finance but he also loved
sports and
during the pandemic he had some free
time so he started writing a newsletter
about interesting sports stories that
had a finance component
so for instance how do you value a
baseball stadium how do you value an nba
team
or why did the weekend the singer of the
weekend
um not take any pay to do the super bowl
halftime show but use seven million
dollars
not only he used seven million dollars
as his own money to
produce the show why would he do that so
this guy would
write a newsletter explaining these
things he he he started as eight months
ago he's got 27
000 subscribers now he quit his job at
jp morgan
and this is what he's going to do the
rest of his life he loves
he loves us he found his dream situation
he combined finance
with sports using idea sex
and boom he's the number not only is in
the top 1 percent
he's the number one writer on the planet
combining
in in the field of sports finance which
didn't really exist before him
so uh you know that's where it gets
really practical
is the idea that you don't pre-judge
the experiment and you just do it
because on the surface saying i'm going
to run for president or i'm going to buy
greenland
feels like there's very little practical
upside compared to
doing blog mashups but you still do it
is that hey
you never know what's going to work out
i just don't judge the idea i had it so
i'm going to do something to follow my
curiosity is that
just the lack of judgment towards
whether it will work or not
yeah and and you can't judge an
experiment because
most experiments fail so you can't say
well i'm pretty sure if i run for
president i'm going to win
you can't say that i'm pretty sure i can
say i'm
if i'm going to do an experiment where i
go on a subway and do stand-up comedy
oh man it's going to be the talk of the
town it's going to be great everyone's
going to start riding the subway to see
james altitude
do comedy but here's what i did though
that that experiment
was pretty good but then i did a further
experiment it made me think
of late night talk shows and i felt like
here was this
it was like i was gonna do a late night
talk show except the subway
was the stage and and the subway riders
were the audience
and when i did my stand-up on the subway
car it was like the monologue
so what would a stand-up what else are
components of a late night
tv show well there's usually a musical
guest
so i found i took video of buskers
on you know those are people who play
like garbage kansas drums
on the subway platforms and so that was
my musical guest
and then i called up a friend of mine aj
jacobs who you probably know
and he had a book coming out and i said
hey come on the subway with me and i'm
going to interview you on the subway
you're going to be my guest
in this in this late night format and so
i did another experiment
which is create a late night talk show
where
uh the format everything is exactly the
same format as a late night talk show
except it takes place on a subway
and we interacted with the subway
writers you know aj and i did
and then i took video of that and i
pitched it
as a tv show i pitched it to an agent
and
the upside of course is i could have had
this amazing tv show of a late night
talk show on a subway
the downside was is that i learn a bit
more about being an entertainer
i do a podcast with my friend aj and i
have fun and i have a fun
story to tell in a video to show and i
did show it to an agent
the practical part is if he had accepted
it it could have made a lot of money for
me
he didn't most experiments fail but
the downside was fun and and i have a
story to tell about it
so so that's uh i do many experiments
that are practical and many that don't
seem practical and even that one might
not seem practical it's just a theory oh
this might be an interesting
format for a late night show um
well maybe it was maybe it wasn't i
don't you know it was just one
experiment
but every experiment has a practical
component even running for president i'm
learning so much about the process and
it's also forced me to learn about the
issues
you never know what practical component
that could have uh
you know maybe it's given me some ideas
that now i can use
to talk to people about you know in
different parties about what what's
going on in in politics and
and in the country i love it well james
i could talk to you for hours
there's always always some new nuggets
going on in that head of yours that i
love just
being a final one i'm listening to guys
the book is called
skip the line i'm holding it here we're
going to link it up down the description
below
go check it out your bling your your
brain is going to get blown
that that became blame your brain will
be blown go check it out james
thank you so much evan i i i thank you
so much i really appreciate it
and you know i i probably didn't do
enough marketing i usually do a lot when
i market a book and i didn't really do
so much
marketing this book i i i was doing an
experiment
see how word of mouth works and and
maybe it'll work maybe
it won't but you know maybe that this i
shouldn't have done as much of an
experiment on
but i'm really grateful to the that you
like the book and that you're helping me
out it's gotten really great feedback on
amazon and
i personally think i've written a lot of
books i personally
love this one because it's so practical
and and i've used all the techniques
and it works for me and and and others
that i've seen so
thanks again for having me on on the
show awesome thank you man
thanks evan if you want to see my last
interview with james
we talked about how to think like a
billionaire check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there going on the
other side of camp
is where all of these billionaires and
where every other successful achiever
ends up going